the aperture was black with a darkness
almost immaterial that tin averseness
was indeed a positive quality for it
obscured such parts of the inner walls
as ought to have been revealed and
actually burst forth like smoke from its
e'en long imprisonment visibly darkening
the Sun as it slunk away into the
shrunken and gibbous sky on flapping
membranous wings the odour arising from
the newly open depths was intolerable
and at length the quick eared Hawkins
thought he heard a nasty slapping sound
down there everyone listened and
everyone was listening still when it
lumbered slobbering ly into sight and
gropingly squeezed its gelatinous green
immensity through the black doorway into
the tainted outside air of that poisoned
city of madness or Johansson's
handwriting almost gave out when he
wrote this of the six men who never
reached the ship he thinks to perished
of pure fright in that occur said
instant the thing cannot be described
there is no language for such abysm zuv
shrieking an innumerable lunacy such
eldritch contradictions of all matter
force and cosmic order a mountain walked
or stumbled God what wonder that across
the earth a Great Architect went mad and
poor Wilcox raved with fever in that
telepathic instant the thing of idols
the green sticky spawn of the stars had
awakened to claim his own the stars were
right again and what an age-old cult had
failed to do by design a band of
innocent sailors had done by accident
after vid until ian's of years great
Cthulhu was loose again and ravening for
tonight three men were swept up by the
flabby claws before anybody turned God
rest him if there be any rest in the
universe they were Donovan karora and
Engstrom Parker slipped as the other
three were plunging frenziedly over the
endless vistas of green crusted rock to
the boat and Johansen swears he was
swallowed up by an angle of masonry
which shouldn't have been there and
angle which was acute but behaved as if
it were up to so only Britain and
Johansson reached the boat and pulled
desperately for the alert as the
mountainous monstrosity flopped down the
slimy stones and hesitated floundering
at the edge of the water steam had not
been suffered to go down entirely
despite the departure of all hands for
the shore and it was the work of only a
few moments of feverish rushing up and
down between the wheel and engines to
get the alert underway slowly amidst the
distorted horrors of that indescribable
scene she began to churn in the lethal
waters lost the masonry of the charnelle
shore that was not of Earth the Titan
thing from the Stars slavered and
gibbered like Polly feigning the fleeing
ship of Odysseus then bolder than the
storied Cyclops great Cthulhu slid
gracefully into the water and begin to
pursue with vast wave rising strokes of
cosmic potency
Britain looked back and went mad
laughing shrilly as he kept on laughing
at intervals till death found him one
night in the cabin was-- Johansen was
wandering deliriously but Johansen had
not given out yet knowing that the thing
could surely overtake the alert until
steam was fully up he resolved on a
desperate chance and setting the engine
for full speed ran lightning-like on
deck and reversed the wheel there is a
mighty eddying and foaming in the
noisome brine and as the steam mounted
higher and higher the brave norwegian
drove his vessel head-on against the
pursuing jelly which rose above the
unclean froth like the stern of a demon
galleon the awful squid head with riling
feelers came nearly up to the basket of
the sturdy yacht but Johansen drove on
relentlessly there was a bursting as of
an exploding bladder a slushy nastiness
of a cloven sunfish a stench of a
thousand open graves and a sound that
the chronicler would not put on paper
for an instant the ship was be filed by
an acid and blinding green cloud
and then there was only a venomous
seizing a stern where God in heaven the
scattered plasticity of that nameless
sky spawned was nebulously recombining
in its hateful original form whilst its
distance widened every second as the
alert gained impetus from its mounting
steam that was all after that Johansson
only brooded over the idol in the cabin
and attended to a few matters of food
for himself and the laughing maniac by
his side he did not try to navigate
after the first bold flight for the
reaction had taken something out of his
soul then came the storm of April 2nd
and the gathering of the clouds about
his consciousness there is a sense of
spectral whirling through liquid gulfs
of infinity of dizzying Rives through
reeling universes on a comet's tail and
hysterical plunges from the pit to the
moon and from the moon back again to the
pit all live and by the chacon aiding
chorus of the distorted hilarious elder
gods and the green bat wind mocking imps
of Tartarus out of that dream came
rescue the village n't the Vice
Admiralty Court the streets of doomed
in' and the long voyage back home to the
old house by edge berg he could not tell
they would think him mad he would write
about what he knew before death came but
his wife must not guess death would be a
boon if only it could blot out the
memories that was the document I read
and now I have placed it in the tin box
beside the bar relief and the papers of
the professor angle with it I shall go
on this record of mine this test of my
own sanity wherein is pieced together
that which I hope may never be pieced
together again I have looked upon all
that the universe has to hold of horror
and even the skies of spring and the
flowers of summer must ever afterward be
poison to me but I do not think my life
will be long as my uncle went as poor
Johansen when
I shall go I know too much and the cult
still lives
Cthulhu still lives too I suppose
again in that chasm of stone which has
shielded him since the son was young his
accursed city is sunken once more for
the village entailed over the spot after
the April storm but his ministers on
earth still bellow and prance and slay
around idle captain monoliths in lonely
places he must have been trapped by the
sinking was within his black abyss or
else the world would by now be screaming
with fright and frenzy who knows the end
what has risen may sink
what has sunk may rise loathsomeness
waits and dreams in the deep and decays
spreads over the tottering cities of men
a time will come but I must not and
cannot think
let me pray that if I do survive this
manuscript my executors may put caution
before audacity and see that it meets no
other eye